[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
Oh
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the Goodbody the chaperone oh good by
the way they'll be along little skewers
everybody well let's get the prize right
right platypus is when you light it will
you ask you to the kitchen stove okay
[Applause]
over the bunk room run off the Galvan's
run not for the guy
Oh quite respectable Oh max doctor oh
thanks will
now that I have dr. Edward we all okay
miss Kraus and we will convey half dr.
Edwards where I go and assist mr.
Mitchell well I guess it had better be
Ellen and then I guess sir
Rex killing dr. Finn yes
right that's what I don't get much of an
opportunity we are not healthy not a
miracle it's on your hair boxes are
overworked yes the first question
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
beautiful night
beautiful rusty here why don't you two
have some no thanks not just now what
happened to the coffee I can carry that
felt business to fire doctor if he
doesn't want to drink he doesn't and
I've never drink anyway good for bender
loosen up a little things like to
seriously people resent that you know
direct some people like Jeff Kearns
bring what about car the Ottoman the
same you've been on the job for two
months now been and we've got turned
down on you you got to get you so the
grapevine tells me where is all is
Charlie well been closed up a ratty
little restaurant in the south end
unsanitary Kern owns it so when Ben
proposes a terrific employee should be
given blood test Kern persuades the
mayor that my esteemed father that this
is an insulting slander against old and
honored citizens in the community the
mayor listens he always listens the
current flag plant to discover what we
delicately refer to as the social
diseases let's drop the subject sharing
okay but take my tip and go easy my
friend politicians don't like Crusaders
some politicians are Crusaders I guess I
put my foot in it I got sixteen a clue
Oh only say what happened to the good
buddy hours ago there here here where I
swear the good bodies all four of us get
it good bodies we're going to be good
boys and girls so we don't need a
chaperone now don't tell me you had any
other intention cannot inari your jokes
I'm very funny charlie
oh no Alice don't be mad we didn't want
anyone killed tours around him you know
you can tell that's a reshuffle
team wins writers everybody has to be so
stuffy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the pain call single example dimension
[Applause]
little bit before and got her a little
it I learned it you so efficient come
out here
yes garlic sense of humor maybe I am a
little stuffy Shepard on business mother
not really it's Charlie Babbitt
redownload in God being with Victorian
you raw that makes them a little bit
elated me I feel like [ __ ]
no school
sugaring oh no thanks I'll walk them
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
no matter with you you're so alright why
can't you kiss me nicely nicely been
skinny now Watson you should have come
along with us Johnny I'll say I should
have I don't know I feel we should go
back to town
sharing okay let's be proper by all
means I'll tell you
[Applause]
exactly found roughly we would have to
rely on others sighs all right Charlie
try it once more but then you fix it
right thing I'm staying I'll get a buck
down tomorrow and the other I can do
with you right
[Applause]
that is completely shot now well you
freakin well 50 miles to mouth and I'm
going to bed good night
I'm not walking anywhere Charlie's right
only till I'm safe what are we going to
do well it's quite a hike to melt and
need them for a couple of starchy
Victorian yeah good night good
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
mr. Williams how do you do dr. Woods
won't you sit down
Thanks what can I do for you
no what can I do for you don't know what
you mean well I wanna cooperate I just
heard about how you close up that source
of current rapidly good move anything
that improves this town is OK by me I'm
Way ahead of most places nothing you
know my club clean in every respect now
why can't all public places be like that
no reason it's home and grave so I'd
like to cooperate nice public spirit
about it I don't think I can help
I need people see in the club outside I
know everybody know and I've got plenty
of influence probably you have mr.
Williams but just what do you think you
could do for a Vista button well I
thought maybe you were planning on some
sort of clean up nothing campaign if you
are figuring on such a campaign maybe I
can get behind you possibly I appreciate
your interest in pursuit of the way you
can help you name it barking it's done
come here this shaded area on the map
represents one of the worst slums in
milk if you could use your influence to
help clear up those slums it would be a
great service should be easy for others
you own most of those buildings really
doctor you seem to know a great deal
about my affairs that's my job and I'm
telling you mr. Williams if you don't
clean up those slums I will
I'm low or moderate calavius guitar me
or I just tell it don't freeze up on the
nightmare hello Leon
you want me to come up to you last night
yeah what are you worrying about them
justice nuts about you whenever I'm busy
that's all I got things on my mind
yeah there are man
[Music]
Pepsi I love you so Mars a hatcheck girl
are you seeing that Edwards going to do
that - no well don't to make trouble a
figure will be saying not much except to
suggest I clean up the slum down on the
south side if I don't feel well at all
well he said it gets too busy we'll take
care of them
but how shorter here keeping tabs on
them look mighty you'll be popular I
know you play hard needle over she drops
in no harm in that
Oh or having anything to do with you
body what do you want about couple
Russian pop see to what I don't get so
much you don't get for some only doing
my duty see that's open the gifts lift
me up five every now and then I don't
even see back to you long here
okay mega part only X square that's
deducted from the two-hundred-year-old
me where what do you know double cross
myself what come and borrow
so how do you like that look you think
he is putting in twenty father act on me
nothing that's known at me or my life
[Applause]
naturally you'll find you're gonna see
any community one hole I'd say that was
one of the healthiest most up-to-date
account anywhere on this continent
second of the most boring I know that's
the trick of course I haven't worked
alone we're a team here in Louisville
and you will secret of our success
doctor with patience and caution
well slowly and ghosts Audrey that is
our motto and the black shirt father
don't be pregnant Charles so far George
I'm not forgetting one very nice cook
got committee meeting well it was nice
to see me doctor we must get together
morrow keep each other info I shot the
Rick my dear good night Q and the most
stimulating conversation dr. father just
loved stimulating conversation then also
this will be smooth that was a
sugar-coated writer Ben what are you
talking about then was just warned to be
a good boy or ad dropped from the team
it's as simple as that
Curtis the meeting is on our I'd say
Charlie you talking little he probably
needs very well all think the best day
good old mr. Goodbody
don't touch me about that Ben and Alan
thought it was dreadfully immoral not to
have a chaperone at the large last
weekend Charlie I graduated shuttle
overloaded okay
you're a lot don't tell me you're going
faster than that dr. Dixon why when I
pick at the harm done by shackled and
stern parents oh yeah huh putting people
against pretty good
sometimes they need guidance
having fun or really good evening I
wonder if you could power out there yes
miss Carter at home not carpet oh yeah
the doctors I just can't do a lot of
work I'm happy when it was I got the
governess - I won't stay
Jane Colin didn't it well not really men
always say that when some excuse
video we made in yes but Allah Clarion
love to grab the thing it nice folks
don't set that
[Applause]
Miriam here in second
[Applause]
[Applause]
hello there
I've been kissing rounded up for that
glad to see you
screaming 1209 screaming your harem
Aaron Carter Allison forever
doctor we have been formal around here
definite influence I hired her aged over
there with my housekeeper engine running
our liability that Rebecca bodily
epicondyle changes thank you onion it's
your turn wrap burn the picture in the
paper when you came to talk and Aaron
have tells about you oh yes that weekend
oh I didn't do that
all right not selfish re-enroll not the
part of your Nightingale so you take on
desk RNA what they should go and again
dr. Olin well let's get acquainted tell
me about this colorful thing oh you feel
like trying to kill a wing by rolling it
down you destroy it here and it goes up
again sometime oh that's why we doctors
and hospitals and social workers can do
more than the single manifestations of
disease and dependency but it takes
group action community action to repeat
these mean and completely destroy them
gosh we have been battling for hours you
haven't been babbling then you've been
talking since i'll see what you mean
then the principal of a high school in
the middle of the city council on
american instead of an uploader I didn't
know each other you have missed
something errand
Oh how long have you been here I'm not
long
I'm sorry I'm so late when jobs were
taken to see me owner disappear every
thousand City for a few days that's all
Charlie drove me home little tremendous
rush back from where pieces down done
or it must be getting very late not to
make a cup of tea yeah let's have a cup
of tea
well go with the cake lon you ready
music my revenge for that part
no no you are a wonderful woman
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
octagon work you know I mean please do
have a drink
not a man about something ready to the
girl fell back down of the city to the
largest area could be she left quite a
great
[Music]
people forgot about the other piece
conservative thing okay fine I know
where we can go over something nothing
quite smart ski runs a lot of miles away
in fact I don't think Kane will take a
break with it
where's Marty Marty come here
[Music]
I got the girl money and we get handsome
sure I thought you'd quit hanging around
again I look at going on again a month
we're like you without the boss said
about you and I see not sexy in anybody
else stupid okay okay I got something
for you on that dust again yeah what our
boy Benny is a man about Thomas F die
with the chick he he's been out the
weekend with Aaron Carter up at the
Mitchell ski lodge cause there's no Lee
on a webinar charlie is there too but
nobody assure us the machines all my
shoes did not get it from my
brother-in-law he's married to my third
sister the one with the Rorick he runs
the garage up in the mountain see laughs
and he's called after the Mitchell's
piastres got a [ __ ] if they get out the
whole deal and it gives me a call we got
an arrangement see so I'm cute this is
the one on a nose Kyoji allows you lots
of cotton every two minutes of it well
can you use it I can use it
[Applause]
[Applause]
roof hang on a second
[Music]
[Applause]
I think I've got a cold
[Music]
no because roughly doing
[Music]
good morning gentlemen
good morning Ben you know Tom the
character yes we've met
is this an official given do you fill it
look very businesslike this morning
anything wrong plenty read this
the marked item near the bottom
[Applause]
but a filthy rotten operator give me the
office of the night class
what are you going to do I'm gonna tell
the senator he's got a rival suit on his
hand don't be a fool what good would
that do you can't not go under the stuff
like this the head mistake thinking
Ellen will you that's who I'm thinking
out no one's asking you to knuckle under
we want you to fight what are we going
to do about that
ignore it can you see yourself and Ellen
being cross-examined by their lawyers oh
look here Carter
never can either dear young Jeff I know
my daughter and I'd come to know you
would like you all I mean is you can't
walk in but without being smeared it's
not worth it for the sake of exposing a
cheap life well I get mad too when I did
that thing when I talked to Mack he
opened my this is more than scandal been
nasty little items like that are sold at
a fat profit to people concerned no one
approached you
no nor Howard why not someone wanted
that printed to discredit you I'd say
but why well you've made enemies made
people uncomfortable they do it again
come women's likely it doesn't matter
who really don't you see this is Marvin
a slur it's a challenge from the
racketeering element I'm already a
little far-fetched
I don't think so someone is out to get
you what are we going to do about it
we fight back after all it's time we
drove the racketeers out of this town
have we gotten some of those weeds then
well
you know I feel and with you all the way
but we three alone alone we won't be
alone do you think we're the only people
in doesn't want to see an end to disease
and farm and poverty we want to prove to
read that infectious community know
we'll find alive by the score but let's
find them let's get to work
now you're talking so we thought our
first move was to call this meeting of
representative community leaders and
discover if you've shared our views as I
have described it and if so to enlist
your support in devising a means like
modern medical cures are most effective
and yet the dangers are still great the
venereal disease rate in most
communities far exceeds medical measures
we must improve our treatment service
and our detection service many many
people have syphilis and do not know
certainly we have the laws to combat the
problem of prostitution we must see to
it that those laws are enforced and we
have the women we have found time and
time again that the prostitute is scaled
and fined but the men the patron is
permitted to go free his crime is as
great as her I feel certain industry
will welcome Lee setting up of medical
units to conduct general examination
long x-rays and blood tests among
employees we businessmen will cooperate
100% run x-rays have uncovered a vast
volume of tuberculosis and yet little
has been done to enlarge our sanitarium
facilities TB cases often have to wait
their turn for admittance and in the
meantime the disease was in many parts
of the country young people are required
to have premarital blood tests before
they can apply for marriage licenses
would dis not be feasible in melton we
of the Roman Catholic clergy have very
clear instructions last couples
contemplating marriage if they have
exchanged prenuptial medical
certificates and if they have not done
so we ask the reason why not what about
instruction on venereal disease and sex
in high school the knowledge first of
all should be given to the parents the
Erdos of the community must be informed
we must have civic support both moral
and material we need Authority and money
I propose mr. Carter mr. McAllister and
dr. Edwards draw up a program for our
approval summarizing and implementing
our findings here tonight and present
that report to the City Council at the
very least possible delay let's waste no
time we will do our level best to
represent adequately the splendid
objective you accept for
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Daphne Daphne Thomas how much ah yes I
do
that's a fine of him you are singing one
of my papers online two hours I wish you
wouldn't sing it though
thought you liked it I do and I
especially like the way you sing it but
it's distracting hear those rich fool
tones come floating out of the kitchen
carrying those final words I get carried
away I can't work and I have to finish
this job tonight well I just stopped
well shouldn't be singing too much
anyway I strain my voice you worried
about Karen I don't know what to expect
from current but Higgins always honest
and beans well but not much vision and
the mayor destroying the wind fifteen
community leaders agreeing on a brief
life this is a pretty strong wind isn't
it would be but Curran and Higgins
dominate the mayor of course we'd have
McAllister backing it up that must have
been even there no thanks Daphne we just
popped in for a minute
to give you the news what news we're
going to be married Oh all the happiness
in the world name well I hope you'll be
very happy Thank You Howard say where's
Ben I thought he'd be here he had to
call in at the hospital but he's coming
aren't you wait for him come on Dione
come out there give your things well for
we might as well stay a little while
yes let me have your coat well I finally
nailed him Fiona I'll probably regret it
for the rest of my life how do you say
such things
oh I know Charlie he's spoiled and
selfish marriage not really what Charlie
wants the only way you could have me was
to marry me but I haven't much in a way
of fun I never was anyone to teach me
anything might talk see I just rose
Oh Ellen you don't know what it means
not to
you're on a darling Ellen I do love him
I hope it works out of course it will
what a goose I am you're going to be
very happy I hope so let's make it a
double little your back your honor you
idiot now don't pretend you don't like
it of course I'm not just crazy brought
you low musk I'm glad I come back you
know dr. Edwards I imagine that was
pathetic
Oh sort of nerve strain that's not too
serious Betty a matter of too many late
hours many parties too much nightlife
and it has keeping here for three days
just to find out there it takes time to
make a thorough examination hospitals
the best place for diagnosis here we can
find out exactly what's wrong but I am
all right out huh Senora
I'm afraid not we're blood tests showed
something called serious well I hate to
have to tell you this if you have a
venereal disease sickness and infected
for some time probably several months
but don't worry with treatment like
painless you could be completely cured I
don't I know this is a terrible shock
for you but you'll have to face it mr.
thanks not only this disease but your
own responsibility that's why I asked
dr. Burris to be here you can help it
helping a great deal dr. black has
kindly agreed to let me come and see you
and ask your help I hope I got to help
us trace down the source of this
infection and what's more help us
discover any possible other infection
what do you think I am a good speaker
okay I'm not judging miss Conine
abducted with a job to do you can help
me do that job in fact you can be of
service to the whole community so what
do I care about the community
get out of here not me alone do you
understand hello
[Applause]
what I have just read to you the worlds
and views of highly responsible
intelligent community leaders as such
they deserve the respect to most
searching consideration of this council
there are no specific proposals some
very specific proposals but the broad
councillor McAlister outlines the
program recommended by our group I want
to emphasize the importance of the anti
VB things of the program by means of a
film doctor it would secure this film
and it speaks for itself most
graphically stop the Edward
perhaps you can set up your projector
right now there isn't a picture show
let's hear your program but it only
takes a few minutes you've used up too
much of this counsels time already
get to the point let's peel the film
later if necessary a most impressive
report and very anxious to hear
conclusions gentlemen here is a foreign
health program for the city of Milton
it's constructed so that private
citizens may work hand in hand with
municipal departments sharing duties and
costs point 1 legal requirements a moral
requiring all persons to secure a
general health examination including
blood tests and lung x-ray before being
issued a marriage license new laws of
necessary and intensified application of
olive laws to prosecute not only
prostitutes for all who derive profit
there from landlords Madame's pimps and
those who maintain Constitution by their
patronage or to medical requirements the
setting up in existing buildings of the
health center for the housing of a VD
clinic a blood test apartment and
headquarters for a mobile medical unit
which would conduct general health
examination long x-rays and blood tests
at the request of any individual or
group of individuals
I may say gentlemen that businessmen
among our group are especially
enthusiastic about this proposal why not
something for nothing
point three the citizen participation
the creation of a permanent body of
representative citizens pledged to
devise and carry out a sustained program
of adult and child education on
community health in all its phases to be
responsible for the raising by public
subscription of one half the cost of the
community center point for municipal
participation the city to provide the
proposed health center referred to about
the city to provide a suitable building
site and provide at least one half the
cost of a large community center
designed to accommodate sports
facilities stage productions public
meetings and a modest art gallery and
museum the purpose of the center being
to provide a constructive environment
for all the citizens of milk there you
have a document a person wrought plan of
attack against disease and delinquency
in the city what kind of wild-eyed
nonsense is this this whole plan is an
insult to the good people of Milton an
insult it's a fantastic slander it
suggested Milton is the city populated
by diseased prostitutes and degenerates
young and old and the cost staggering
hundreds of thousands of dollars the
cost would be a lot cheaper in the long
run than the present cost of curing
disease you're not a member of this
council Edwards gentlemen please I'm
going to have sex education for children
expose our youngsters to stuff like that
I've explained the sex facts are only a
part of a broad sex won't be about these
blood tests x-rays how many people
really need them what do these fools
want to do stick needles and everybody
in town treat our young people like
group chattel I feel that all these
things could be carried out in the
sanctity of the home oh well any
sensible concern our noses Judy in this
regard then the fathers of this
community are neither sensible nor
concerned gentlemen we've given you one
damaging statistic after another the
alarming incidence of venereal disease
here in Multan the consumption of
alcohol by minors the volume of moral
delinquency the cravat sanitarians right
here in this city can you possibly
ignore these facts and bleat about costs
and crackpots call the facts offensive
if you wish but as representatives of
the people you dare not turn your backs
on them nor on the need for a program of
action perhaps we let this idea take us
by surprise
let's study it I hope that a committee
of three be appointed to investigate a
report back to the council I second that
motion
I nominate current car this is a mighty
important committee I think the bear
should be Dominator I'd be the lesser
gentleman and it is an important
committee man you've got train already
got that is that your wish gentlemen
getting late I will wager so I can put
the fill you should see the film let the
committee Silverdome when do we need
I'll call you well at least we've got a
committee yes we went through a fast of
meetings and Curran will try to top the
plan to death an old strategy of his
there'll be a whispering campaign
opposition generated but we never get to
the public with this idea they'll be so
influenced against oh well the public
Mack that's it we won't wait for current
to get in his dirty work we'll take this
idea to the people and set the award our
meeting exactly but we'll have that
meeting pride speeches leaflets poems
we'll start a publicity campaign between
now and the meeting there what maybe
what's there once a year the council
meets in the presence of the public an
old custom here then my boy has somebody
said somewhere we've only just begun to
fight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
look even the decent newspapers are
against it it sounded fun huh I guess
it's just so easy to stir up prejudice
and fear for Dad it was sick thank you
sir for what caste it's not his fault
Cullinan is tried to start everything
well we just have to keep on fighting
you're a coward of thing Ellen hi folks
am I breaking something up Albert hello
Charlie
you ready to go ban early up north to
the ski lodge help sticks up for the
honeymooners all right then so did you
Kelly I guess I forgot I don't think
I'll be able to make it you haven't a
single appointment I just checked why
don't you go boom the drag will be a
goal what do you come I can't really but
you'll go to you okay Ellen you have
been well trained I bought you my pet
[Music]
Leona can have her flowers I'll take
tiny ransom yeah my little wife to be
will probably check this stuff up when
she sees it
women hate to have things arranged for
them like to do it themselves you'll
find that out soon enough man if you
ever stop chasing germs and start
chasing women yes my chasing days are
over
well they should be you've chased and
caught a very lovely girl see that you
deserve it Yes Doctor
hey the place looks good ladies a pen
what's this
Oh some trinket of leiana's I'll take
that
[Applause]
[Music]
an ancient indiscretion
our ancient chat doesn't discuss the
things he does with his doctor few weeks
ago when Leona was in the city very
ancient
they it all then stop talking like a
made man what business is it of yours
anyway
come on we're going back to my office
honestly Ben this is a lot of rough all
right give me your old blood test but
don't interfere in my private life
I've told you it takes time for us
doctors to make sure if you're going to
be a silly young fool running around you
owe it to your future wife to make
absolutely certain you can't get married
until you are how long is that might
take ten weeks or even longer postpone
the marriage indefinitely I should say
not silly young fool there are these new
drugs even if anything were wrong three
911
[Music]
hello hello miss Karen this is dr.
Edwards yeah I'd like you to come over
to my office immediately
I love doctors I've got nothing to talk
to you about
I have Charlie Mitchell here and your
bracelet oh all right
as soon as I can goodbye better sit down
[Applause]
all right or not come up here they get
something very important ball good
government a universe conscious
government go slowly
be sure the patient patience and caution
oh sorry I'm sorry
Oh exactly Christmas on this Mitchell
I'm out there see waiting for you boss
waiting suicide door comes back see
what's he doing here I think I following
down the corridor to the back she goes
into Edwards office I'm surprised you
can see we don't go for this edge
whatever we was not possible I'm not
well and curiously so I could be too
long and I sleep in difficult you empty
but any other office I hear voices
it was Patsy and European mayor trying
they're saying this guy Edward is up to
something comical look then when you get
to the funk whatever it is yes what do
you want anyway I want you to tell
Charlie the truth what do you mean when
you're not coming dad to get to drag me
down me Dexter that you're the only
wanted to speak it's your duty
I don't seem to be able to convince you
of that then you're not going to pry my
life look will you get to the point very
well I'm going to show you something and
after you've seen it perhaps you come
over to my point of view and realize how
important it is for both of you to
cooperate with me
what's the meaning of this Sara my Matt
what he got on you two countless is a
doctor's office what goes on in here of
secret I wonder do you mean you might be
digging for dirt against our two kids in
order to force Mitchell Anita back allow
the health campaign that they can big
name for yourself you might have told
your family as your doctor instructed
you to told what and to be what are you
talking about I'll leave them alone and
you mean there's really something wrong
touchy tell me well it's enough now
[Applause]
[Music]
I guess
ah maybe I asked Patsy and Charlie here
together so they could see what might
happen to them it's doubtful whether
that will happen thanks to science but
it could have I think it's most
appropriate that you two gentlemen
dropped in you need to see these films
right here as much as your children do
[Applause]
sit down
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
our setlist the Crippler the describe
the killer
usually contracted sooner or later by
man associating with prostitutes or
indulging and promiscuous sex
relationships so often acquired by girls
and foolishly become sexually intimate
with man they meet as dance hall pickup
or at the drinking party and the story
of Jerry Anderson again and again
Australia and kerryanders Jerry Anderson
how did you happen to come into the
clinic I couldn't afford to go to a
private doctor I didn't know what to do
call the County Health Department see if
they couldn't do something for me solder
coming see you what's your total yeah
alright I've got a pretty bad sore down
here mm-hmm let's just stretch out on my
table over there I will have a look at
you come over here I wants to see this
little corkscrew devil is causing all
your trouble
[Applause]
this dark hue test shows up the
spirochetes can you see them reeling
back and forth across the slide yes what
do Carmo spirochetes
those are the damage that causes
syphilis
[Applause]
I guess that finishes me now I have to
leave home quit school and go someplace
where people don't know who I am
now Jerry you know you can't meet any
problem by running away from it you may
not realize it but we're very lucky in
math because we're catching this
sometime UK Oh miss John the penitents
nail injection yes but dr. I can't take
a chance on the folks there is a coupon
on our business now don't worry about it
you can go about your clients play
basketball or tennis or dogs in any
other sport
gee Donna please roll up your sleeve and
nobody need ever know that you have
syphilis you have to report it really
and not let's a single treatment for at
least one year literally I feel like
living again
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
she got you that that didn't hurt a bit
I always heard this chance for syphilis
were painful how did he go to a doctor
who knows his business
I don't know how to thank you doctor
just come into my office and give me the
name of the guy oh thank you
I call it another one come on you doctor
I kind of hate to do that I'm no stupid
Saddam hey breathe now Jerry a lot of
men have a false sense of chivalry about
giving the name of the woman on paper
we're not going to do anything harmful
to the girl and your name won't be
brought into it we only want to bring
her in for examination and King Jerry
has done his part now the health
department swing into action to do
theirs there's health officials studying
the information on the card stand into
the department by the doctor who
examined Jerry Anderson arranged for
visiting health nurse after discussing
the case for a few moments the nurse
that's out to locate the girl and in a
friendly way and a confidential
interview suggests that the girl visit
the clinic in the interest of our own
health and welfare
upon reporting to the clinic for an
examination man interview a sample of
the girls blood is taken and sent to the
departmental laboratory for analysis
this contact or suspected contact
follow-up procedure is very important to
the individual concerned because so
often they do not even suspect they are
suffering from venereal disease the
laboratory examination of the blood
samples generally known as the Wasserman
test is a complicated procedure
requiring close attention to details it
is interested only to thoroughly skilled
personnel and handle these tests quickly
and efficiently by number they never
know the name of the patient involved in
this instance the tests confirm that
Gerry sex partner had syphilis there is
no doubt of it the laboratory report is
positive
surplus has struck and it's germs are
implanted in new victims once again just
a little over three weeks since Jerry
met the girl who infected him with
syphilis which began in her case most
probably to rent-a-cars with an infected
person prior to her relations with Jerry
Anderson now we see what really happens
in such a case as the germs of syphilis
call spirochetes attack the cervix or
neck of the uterus within the female
reproductive system shortly after
infection the primary lesions or
Shanker's as they are commonly called
appear as small red sores where the
spirochetes entered the bloodstream such
as the labia or lips of the vulva on the
vaginal wall and the cervix
since these sores are painless and often
well concealed within the female organs
it is easy to understand why women in
particular can be infected and never
know it syphilis can also in very rare
cases be acquired by kissing a person
with a chancre on the lip and
occasionally doctors and nurses
contracted in handling syphilitic
patients in which event the shank is
appear on the finger like this
throughout the primary stage and during
the quiescent period of from 6 weeks to
3 months following the appearance of the
Shanker's the germs are disseminated to
all parts of the body they are the
bloodstream their natural highway
network reaching to every vital organ of
the human system the disease now enters
upon what is known as the secondary
stage and various manifestations may
begin to appear either singly or in
combination such as headaches
accompanied by a general feeling of
depression of being unwell with the half
sores in the mouth sore throat or
swollen glands the infected bloodstream
they give rise to skin rashes on the
body and face or the hair roots may be
affected and unsightly patches appear at
different places or as so often happens
a general falling of the hair during
coming from all parts of the scalp
health authorities have ascertained by
careful checking of their record but one
case of separation usually results in
three month and those three another
three therefore it is your duty yours
and mine
should any of these manifestations
appear such as headaches sores in the
mouth sore throat swollen glands skin
rashes hair patches etc especially after
exposures through illicit sex relations
to report to a private physician or
health clinic for examination and the
blood test which is simplicity itself
and when carried out by a skilled
operator if something less has to be
almost unnoticeable attorney key is
first applied to the arm which is then
thoroughly cleansed with alcohol a large
syringe is not definitely inserted into
a vein and the quantity of blood slowly
withdrawn for laboratory analysis
purposes and that's all there is to it
but the beneficial results may be
far-reaching and save untold misery and
unnecessary suffering in many years
if in doubt at any time don't delay get
a blood test today your own health and
the health of your loved ones is far too
precious to gamble away time is the
all-important factor in the war on
syphilis from treatment by a qualified
physician or at a health clinic is
insurance against the devastating
effects of late syphilis which may
appear anywhere from 5 to 10 15 or even
20 years after the original infection if
the disease is not detected and treated
in the early stages the heart attack the
usual cardiac symptoms associated with
heart trouble in reality syphilis in
disguise because syphilis will simulate
practically every disease known to
medical science
stricken without warning from the very
depths of our being even death
yes is often the penalty paid for
neglect of this scourge
of the human race when the spirochetes
attack the optic nerve blindness can be
the tragic aftermath of this fearful
disease if as when they invade the
central nervous system locomotor ataxia
paralysis of the lower limbs often
occurs but when they attack the brain
then we pay the terrible price they're
Paris's with the pitiable hallucinations
gradual loss of speech eventual mental
imbalance and death tragic human wrecks
on the casualty list the great despair
all is the only thing with your memory
memory on the present that Messiah and I
or your spirits especially under this
Empire you have a night with a hot
annuity goddess c'mon no one light dial
with my one dream see this after me
lovely Lilly Lilly Lilly Lehman
understand cruelly were only from coupon
on a truly rural a longer liquid
electricity in a physics st in these
great cases of syphilis the final test
is often the only means of determining
the true cause of the patient's
condition like the blood test we saw
earlier the technique involves insertion
of a needle
only this time a hollow one into the
spinal canal and the spinal fluid for
the laboratory analysis is caught in
test tubes as it drips through the
hollow needle from the spinal column
today in virile all that is known about
syphilis
many physicians take a spinal as an
extra measure of precaution in all cases
of patients receiving anti syphilitic
treatments before discharging the most
completely cured
[Applause]
[Applause]
what are you doing right so I got my boy
you gotta put on your son Tony you spell
oh is it all
I saw em oh oh
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
great others by a statistician I got
everything or exactly the same yes
please and many my wife she's in this
room where she got her sister so please
back to Aria pie I still here went to
part of the guru no - oh we should
interpret horribly wrong
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but some other doctor don't you run a
Tory she's a bride
he's a boy huh yes I asked for money my
money and she's okay she's wrong for
that mirror the right of my money was a
rather but your faces in the water I do
it someone Johnny your son was born dead
Bobby what's it
well I've got a pretty good idea Johnny
I'll have to ask you a few questions for
ice cubes or questions we're not down
Tony I'm better way to your wife no
please and I read me crazy so what's a
bit all right
did anyone ever tell you Tony because
that's just with summer I got a business
card I want you to think back carefully
do you remember ever having a soul that
didn't hear very bad no no I look what
it
yes sir birth two years ago I said
before I was a man I got a little sore
but but I find someone satellite
Veronica gets our life I saw a girl way
but no medicine you could buy ever cured
that's useless I'm almost your syphilis
killed your baby don't you see a
syphilitic store will grow away without
any treatment in time but the germs stay
in your body yeah I don't I'm afraid
that you gave Maria syphilis and she
gave it to the baby
[Applause]
the fathers visit upon start babies and
these children born deformed unsightly
and handicapped throughout their life or
like this little boy with the doctor
death for the rest of his life venereal
disease can be cured thanks to medical
science and particularly syphilis could
be completely stamped out if all engaged
couples went to a doctor for premarital
consultation a thorough physical
examination before marriage and a
routine blood test if every expectant
mother made certain that she received
adequate prenatal care including the
routine blood tests early in pregnancy
then congenital syphilis could be
stamped out if we demanded and supported
routine blood tests for employees in
every industry if we demanded and
supported adult classes of instruction
in sex education and if we all whenever
our own status within doubts reported to
a private physician or a health clinic
and asked for a blood test then indeed
the day would come when everyone would
know cure and suppress become a disease
of the past within the very near future
[Applause]
that is what I tried to fill at the
council meeting the other night that is
part of what the four-point program is
aimed again that's awesome then it will
be alright in time yes we can cure this
disease we can cure the body that is but
the spirit or something else it might
their permanence cuz that's up to you
thanks then and we'll do whatever you
say now I don't know yes it'll be
alright
paksy don't worry patty it's all my
fault baby let me repeat : all this is
between the five of us
[Applause]
you mean the different get out but not
on Iran I think I made that quite clear
mister man yes but the wedding will have
to be postponed
in a second young man has program our
differences in that critical ones we're
not fighting for power for votes
we're fighting disease stunted minds and
stunted bodies come on dad
[Music]
well that's it
what he has to do for the city fathers
fixed up a job for me and fans arranged
for treatment there it looked quite
normal to post on the way son
Leona
hey with me there I let me turn those a
lot of loving another what to do
just caught something somebody's got it
wrong little bit there or try and make
up for
I know that town then I'd got to really
pull it off tomorrow night so I'm not
condemning the people of Melton was
decent and intelligent identity many
were but they didn't edit the garden our
fire departments
this is James and asked me there people
did jail they never got tested it
against you see a fine kindly woman
she's been made to fear a hard yes
you've done your bit you stand on the
others now if you're turned on tomorrow
you don't have to stop a lamb
no clumpy he won't do it and I'll do it
now please try to relax and have a
pleasant evening you're right as usual
through here yes thank you Jeff jang-ho
reports bowling ready bad luck
take a seat down to another country
frenzy all set to marry in November 1919
he's not got through that's for the
wedding off that Christmas some January
outdoor burned down for the foot today
dr. June come June 10th resolve our
broken base well person men are just one
thing after another got the bad Alec
took degrees after just a consulting to
start trying to find a favorable day
them to still ain't very but there's no
such back in and stolen when burn and
Ellen get married
libero hello hello Karen yes I imagine
Ethelred good the minute
Karen wants to see you and me in your
office not generally yes hello Karen
yep that'll be alright but half an hour
right
what is Karen one I don't know daddy
just have to fear well let's go and find
out maybe the trick
maybe you shouldn't go I don't think
it's anything like that
[Applause]
my master can take a chair I was turned
I haven't much to say as you like I came
to give you something
Carter I want you to swear you won't
open this apply and find out what's in
it for two weeks
can i decent Lee and honestly make that
comment I give you my word for what it's
worth
very well I'll do as you say one more
thing don't bring up your health program
tomorrow night you'll kill it if you
don't we're prepared to risk then don't
bring it up get it postponed we're not
going to let you win that easily I don't
want to win anymore I won't oppose you
you what I will oppose you friends of
course if you do we'll put it over
tomorrow night or any night the hometown
don't look the issue will be decided
tomorrow night wait wait two weeks you
promised in two weeks that will win for
you that's all
[Applause]
I think Marian is right this is some
trick no I don't think so
[Music]
or not we can't wait much longer earn
liver mr. looting in his life just be
half an hour late already we have degree
soon what do you make it about what's
coming up - I don't know
look Mac ok things appear to be going
against us let's press for a
postponement underground the committee
hasn't completed its study right
I thought you were going ahead tonight I
changed my mind garage
we go in we can't wait until the
mountain welcome to this annual meeting
[Applause]
gentlemen of the council this is our
agenda for this evening
the minutes of the last meeting will be
lighting and 1/3 the resurfacing of
heart on the street there apart from the
special committee to discuss community
please abstain from these our face this
meeting must proceed with the quorum
gentlemen we will proceed with our
business
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's try would be good there are lots
about a little private show they hear
the call the movie for the round truth
[Applause]
what time is it except after nine we
should be bouncing an oath not to get to
the station to receive
switch on a radial one of you what's
going on at the Town Hall
[Music]
[Applause]
that concludes the very quick support
I'll move the departments at your tender
for the waiting job second daddy and now
we come to the special committee of the
point mr. bear before hearing a report I
wish to reduce their health recover
register my strong disapproval of the
tactics used by councillor Carter and
his crowd of busybodies in bypassing the
entirety of this culture the culture
that we are part of the committee to
study the proposed plan until their
committee acted and council acted no one
should have stirred up a public law very
congested what the counselor but there
was no cure till the Health Program with
attacks of maliciously impaired lips lip
reading clap they conducted with
restraint the council will have to
adjourn to the City Hall I broke a
mister now these people are vitally
concerned in this issue I think that
should be settled when a person
our reporting certainly we must have our
own orderly procedure I will refresh
your memories on the Greek submitted to
Council by panel your father are the
counselors sufficiently familiar with
the brief they were in the absence of
the committee John yeah well in the
absence of comfort
come I will refer to the commissioner
you know as well as I do that the
committee was stalled by council occur
and each time it met three times row
there's nothing to repeal then rather
subject on the agenda I move would be
deferred for at least two weeks over a
secondary I say what's the matter you
afraid to discuss this crackpot scheme
under the second I can do it right
through the bill discussion where's Kern
have you got him locked up somewhere
[Applause]
[Applause]
- man ion compared with this audiences
feeling
American research down here down
[Music]
well
first card I want
come on book in that much time except
not all a strap on we're not going to
the station
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's my repulsive thought I'd let you
heal a counselor Karen has to say about
this health program I think it's the
only thing pronouncing I found that out
hope you'd find it out too in a couple
of weeks but never mind that
last night I gave cosmic Carter
seasonable for their structure open it
in two weeks that was to give me time to
make it get away made it to them they
should prove to you that well
I wish to declare that I'll make this
statement of my own free will and in a
normal state of mind for nine years I
have blended the city of Melton in
partnership with Marty Williams
therefore I associate myself in every
respect with the charges I lay against
Williams he is owner of a gambling house
and boarding house at 140 park driveway
that's a lie he sells liquor illegal in
his club he cooperates with the editor
of the leg Vienna blackmail racket
Williams and I paid the editor of the
magpie $1,000 to discredit the health
program we also paid man to start a
whispering campaign against the program
I suggest to the citizens of Nelson that
there are the jail William go running
out of town I've removed myself neither
the rats have done anything but harm to
this community I hope this statement
convinces you that the opposition to the
health program of artificial from the
staff so far as its beginnings are
concerned I suggest those of you who
honestly opposed the scheme reconsider
your afflictions free from the influence
of such as Williams and myself I swear
this is true so help me God
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
around
well I will never understand it it
doesn't ever not Sakura conscience
impossible
perhaps not to the brain tasty so to
courage
so then what's the next move just the
next move all figured out but we're only
given certain serious accelerometer last
day tomorrow I believe the government is
going well for a few more rocks here for
others run away I love whoever holidays
no black in installing granite wood
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
Oh